i think people
um
one don't exactly realize why resistance
training is beneficial for bone health
and two
uh fail to appreciate just how [ __ ]
strong your muscles are so uh the
the aspect of resistance training that
is most beneficial for bone health is
the compressive forces on the bone like
basically muscle is contracting uh and
it's it's spanning the length of a bone
uh maybe it's spanning two joints maybe
it's uh originating on a bone and
inserting past the end of the bone but
basically when that muscle is
contracting it's putting compressive
force uh on the bone and that is the
stimulus for bone remodeling cool stuff
uh and so i think a lot of people
um
you know when we're
looking at say optimizing squat
biomechanics or something like that
we're generally quantifying external
forces so basically what are the forces
that the barbell is placing on the body
that we then have to overcome
and so i think a lot of people think
about bone remodeling from a similar
paradigm almost like you look at the
external resistance and the sorts of
forces that the external resistance is
placing on the bones and the joints and
you're like okay like that is what's
causing the compressive forces leading
to bone remodeling but most of the
compressive forces that your bones are
feeling are actually just coming from
the muscle contraction itself so for
example if you're interested in
uh like forces on the femur
like compressive forces on the femur
maybe they're greater in the squat than
the knee extension because like you know
you have the bar pressing down on your
body like there are some external
compressive forces uh resulting from
just the load of the bar itself but most
of the compressive forces on the femur
are just coming from the quads
contracting really hard so
it's not like there's an order of
magnitude difference of compressive
force on the femur from the squat versus
the knee extension
um
so that's the first thing like most of
those forces are just coming from the
the force of the muscle contraction
itself and then two your muscles are
very strong um like the human body
is built in a way
where
we're designed for mobility more so than
force output
so for example uh
i think this is just easiest to see with
the bicep like your bicep inserts very
close to your elbow so uh you know it's
like the the
length from your
like the distance from the
middle of your elbow to your hand is
probably like 10 times greater than the
distance from the insertion of your
bicep to the center of the elbow joint
itself so essentially like you know if
you were to curl
50 pounds
with one hand say
your bicep is probably contracting with
around 500 pounds of force uh like that
that's just how it has to work for you
to be able to overcome that external
resistance
500 pounds of force is a ton of force
like i i don't think most people like if
you can curl 50 pounds with one hand i
don't think it's going through your head
like oh my biceps are producing four or
five hundred pounds of contractile force
right now but they are uh and that's
that's how basically all of your muscles
at basically all of your joints work
your muscles are
originate and insert very close to the
joints that they cross
so they have to be contracting with an
enormous amount of force to
move an external resistance
so
you know
even if you're doing
relatively low intensity resistance
training your muscles are still
contracting with a ton of force to move
that resistance and they're contracting
with more force if it's a higher
resistance but
you're putting a lot of compressive
forces on your bones if you're doing
anything that's really even remotely
challenging within
the realm of resistance training
so
my advice is basically just do
resistance training
and i'm sure there is an intensity
somewhere that would be too low like you
know if if you're just doing single
joint exercises and you're using weights
that you can do for sets of 200 like
yeah maybe that's not enough contractile
force to lead to robust bone remodeling
but if you're doing resistance training
with any sort of load that becomes
challenging after fewer than 20 or 30
reps you're putting
an enormous amount of compressive forces
on your bones
which seems to be more than sufficient
for bone remodeling to either improve
bone mineral density or preserve it as
you age